I think that there is from a young age
as a boy man you're somewhat held
accountable from from then you know so
if you do something wrong especially I'm
Nigerian so if you did something wrong
you'll hear reveal that when he comes
home he's gotta figure so you know you
you're told very early on your
consequences your actions have
consequences and so you need to make
sure that you don't do the wrong things
in order to not have those consequences
but a lot of times
are do you think certain cultures don't
have that same energy when it comes to
women and that might be why
yeah I just think self-awareness in it I
feel like as a man you're forced to have
that you know I mean from early days
when you're in the playground you know
I'm saying if you're fat you're the
goalkeeper
but it just is what it is you know I'm
saying like you get picked lost if
you're not the guy no one complains like
everyone kind of knows like there's
always there's an accountability there's
a hierarchy amongst men like we just
know from early like where we kind of
fitting in it like we live in a world
where
we get shown and told where we are all
the time and what what we are in it and
I just feel like for women there isn't
really that but I think their friends
just lie to them too much
leading on from that as well I think
it's self-awareness if you're a man and
you're short fat and you're broke the
world will tell you as soon as you enter
the dating Marketplace or you enter the
world on what your status is whereas a
woman if you're if you're overweight
you'll probably have a body body
positivity group say that it's the right
way to be so I think there's a lot of
ways to Mummy cuddle women where there
is men aren't afforded that luxury
um
well to emulate what the Magnum said
um yeah men are forced to have to live
in in reality from Young
um girls growing up are just never told
no
so they grew up with this idea that you
know the world kind of revolves around
them so that's why I mentioned that you
know men have to create their value for
our life where women are are given their
value so with that you'll afforded two
different mentalities as you're growing
up and going through life and that
allows women to to operate from this
facade of what the reality shows so when
anything goes against that that kind of
cognitive dissonance there's a there's a
competiveness there was that so um
question for the women
is is it just me is this just something
that I see where women don't take as
much accountability as men do
or have you seen that in real life like
do you agree do you disagree
um you can start okay I kind of
partially agree but at the same time
there was uh something that the last guy
said that just triggered something in me
like that that's just not true like I
think women do take accountability and
they are shaped from young as well the
levels of accountability are very
different and I definitely agree
um the fantasy spin I think is very
feminine and the kind of like I'm gonna
I'm gonna reshape reality I think that
is a feminine trait but that doesn't
mean that both sexes don't have an issue
with accountability I absolutely think
that there is an issue with
accountability in society for all Sexes
at this moment
where do you see that men don't take
accountability
I think men don't take accountability
for the this status and
um actual kind of weight that they have
put on themselves and they complain
about it like it's women that have kind
of put this weight on their shoulders
and how they should shape their reality
is like because of women and and women
don't have that same pressure I think
they've done that to themselves can I
have a specific example I'm just I don't
understand what you're talking about
even just being like okay so I the role
of being the breadwinner or the one that
has to provide everything I think that
is men that have put that on themselves
I don't think that has anything to do
with women you know you don't think that
has anything to do with women when women
want a guy that makes um at least 30
percent more than them no right I don't
think there are that many women that
think that like that no no it's if you
survey women and ask them they want a
man that makes at least 30 more than
that and if and if a woman one of the
number one indicators of divorce is if a
woman out earns the man
would that not come from men 100 what
would they not be the ones that are not
comfortable no no because because the
women initiate divorce so women leave a
70 to 80. no no 70 to 80 of the time
women leave and 90 of their college
educated so the higher up a woman goes
in terms of income and Status the more
likely she leaves okay now you're saying
she's leaving because she's earning more
and no I'm saying that she may be like
I'm not satisfied in this relationship
because
he has an issue with me earning more and
I don't want to stay in this Dynamic so
from from what I've seen in the guys you
could maybe correct like you can tell me
what you've seen because you guys you
know you I I see the girl saying I I
found when girls move up and and might
making money they're around more men
that make more money than them so I
think
on some level they kind of wish they
were with the men they were working with
rather than their husbands
so they kind of see what they're not
getting and then they they leave I I can
see that in some circumstances but I
actually think the troubles in a house
when a woman is earning more isn't
necessarily about that Dynamic
this goes back to women's a woman's
nature so we all had the term hypergamy
so women are married for across up
social hierarchies so naturally women
are programmed to always get the best
that they can get so at the time when
she got married to her man that might
have been the best that she could get at
the time but as she elevates herself
past him then she's in a new tax bracket
with new men who are at a higher level
therefore that her Perkins nature starts
to kick in the goodnesses I can do
better than what I currently we're
neglecting that the man in this
situation is also contributing to the
dynamic of that relationship it is
contributing and is acting on it so yes
a man wouldn't divorce a woman
necessarily because she owns one of them
because she owns one but it may be hell
in that and this is the part that nobody
is going into so should she stay in a
house where it's hellish but this is
something hold on where are we going
because I just feel like the goal post
just got moved like this
only less than his wife he tends to be
more passive so what are the chances
that he would actually be raising hell
in the house and you also have to think
about this logically as well what if
we're talking about such a higher
percentage figure of 70 of women leave
but the more higher educated more money
they make you can't then argue like
logically that most of those situations
I've got the man's giving her Hell she's
doing better for herself why is there
not surveys on actually the reasons why
the dominant reason for one is financial
and a second is infidelity yeah so women
leave for financial reasons
women and men and women and men cheat at
similar rates it's like 23 26 financial
reasons that are cited could that not
literally be that we had disharmony in
our house because I was earning more but
this is of England because you know or
what type financial reasons are you
talking about that the finances aren't
enough so she has to leave and find
better because a lot of times a lot of
times women don't like to have to do
more work in terms of that you know but
we're paying for bills but what so are
the initial question was you said men
are held accountable and they put that
on themselves but what I'm saying is I
think the data indicates that men are
held accountable for this because if
your woman out earns you she's out the
door
so they they men have to deal with a
consequence
where we're women where if a woman if a
woman gains a bunch of weight in a
marriage which to me is like similar to
the equivalent like usually the men
don't leave
what you'll be saying if a woman puts on
weight it's the same as if she earns
more no I'm saying like I think that the
equivalent of a woman a woman gave me a
hundred pounds is like a man losing a
job and refusing to work I would say
it's similar in terms of Attraction
instead of what what we are what we're
attracted to
okay because we women are attracted to
money money and Status whereas men we're
visual creatures yeah okay so if you
take the visual aspect away from it then
that's when they start treating cheating
with the secretary you know I can kind
of uh see where that's going I I half
kind of agree yeah so what I'm saying is
is women don't seem to fit like I don't
know a lot of men in real time that are
leaving their woman because she gained
weight
but I do know a lot of women that out
earn their boyfriends or their husbands
and leave so what I'm saying is women
don't face the consequence and then men
do